[Música]
cuando era pibe uno de los juegos que
más me gustaba era sumergirme debajo del
agua y ver cuánto tiempo podía aguantar
sin respirar
general eran unos diez o quince segundos
a veces llegaba a los treinta y cuando
llegaba a los cuarenta paz me sentí un
superhéroe anfibio pero obviamente
siempre volvía a la superficie a
respirar
últimamente siento que hago algo
parecido con el celular fue igual no
mirarlo como cuando aguantaba la
respiración
claro no son unos segundos ni los
minutos son unas horas
a veces cuando me voy de vacaciones
puedes llegar a hacer un par de días
pero a la larga siempre vuelvo a mirarlo
y vuelvo porque el celular las redes y
la web no son sólo herramientas
tecnológicas sino que se han convertido
en el nexo a través del cual respiramos
el oxígeno digital
este oxígeno digital es el aire que
necesitamos para evitar un contexto
virtual pero no por eso menos real en el
que sucede gran parte de nuestra vida
el entorno digital
el surgimiento de este entorno digital
es un cambio histórico fundamental
durante cientos de miles de años los
seres humanos fuimos nómades subsistimos
básicamente de la casa de la pesca y la
recolección
y vivimos condicionados fundamentalmente
por los fenómenos naturales como las
lluvias o las nevadas
hace aproximadamente unos 10 mil años
empezamos a desarrollar la agricultura y
nos volvimos sedentarios
y con el surgimiento de la civilización
urbana hace unos 5000 años nuestra vida
empezó a depender no solo de lo que
sucede en el entorno natural sino
también de lo que pasa en el entorno
urbano como por ejemplo el estado del
tránsito o si se cortó la luz
hace 20 años que me dedico a estudiar
cómo nos informamos
hasta hace muy poco era muy común
escuchar en las entrevistas de
investigación que la gente me dijera que
una de las primeras cosas que hacía al
despertarse en extender la tele o la
radio y escuchar rápidamente cómo viene
el tiempo y el tránsito
o sea tener un pantallazo del entorno
natural y del entorno urbano antes de
comenzar el día
hace unos años se empezó a agregar cada
vez con más frecuencia
agarrar el teléfono celular es el estar
en la mesita de luz
y ver cuántos mensajes nuevos en
whatsapp
y qué novedades hay en las cuentas de
facebook twitter de snap chat de
instagram todo eso desde que se fueron a
dormir
o sea cada vez más
empezamos nuestro día con un pantallazo
de los tres entornos en los que sucede
nuestra vida el natural
el urbano y el digital
durante el día miramos el celular un
promedio de unas 80 veces antes de irnos
a dormir
y eso le sumamos la cantidad de tiempo
que pasamos con la compu o incluso con
la tablet cuesta realmente encontrar un
momento en el que no estamos conectados
pero no es sólo una cuestión de tiempo
sino también de intensidad emocional
es muy común escuchar que el celular se
ha convertido en una parte del cuerpo
una mano más lo de la cual por lo tanto
cuesta mucho desprenderse
para una investigación que hicimos con
colegas en argentina hace un par de años
entrevistamos a más de 100 personas en
distintos puntos del país
una de ellas nos contó que en un viaje
siendo de una provincia a la otra cuando
llegó a destino se dio cuenta que se
había olvidado el celular
un pariente le dijo no te preocupes te
lo alcanzó en un par de días
ahora esta persona contaba en la
entrevista que aún sabiendo que eran
solo dos días de ausencia ella sin el
celular sentía que se moría
y se sentía que se moría porque lo que
le faltaba más que el celular en el
oxígeno digital
este oxígeno digital es distinto del que
respiramos con nuestros pulmones
una diferencia clave es que el oxígeno
digital nos permite respirar atmósferas
múltiples y diversas a la vez
como cuando participamos de muchas
interacciones con distintos grupos de
gente que viven en lugares distintos y
todo esto a través de redes sociales
distintas
es como que estamos permanentemente
viendo y siendo vistos
hay una espectativa doble
por un lado sentimos que tenemos un
acceso casi permanentemente como una
ventana abierta casi permanentemente
hacia la vida de los otros a lo que
hacen a lo que dicen incluso a lo que
sienten
por otro lado claro está la expectativa
inversa y nuestros contactos muchas
veces sienten que tienen derecho a tener
una ventana casi permanentemente abierta
hacia nuestras vidas
y como si el bayern se cruzará con el
exhibicionista
tanta visibilidad atrae pero agota al
mismo tiempo
nuestra sociabilidad se multiplica y
sentimos que nos cuesta mucho
desconectarnos
y cuanto más joven se es más cuesta esta
desconexión
el invierno de este año una noche
caminando por la avenida corrientes en
pleno corazón porteño
[Música]
vi una escena que me impactó
fue una escena tristemente antigua y
moderna a la vez
eran un chico y una chica muy jovencitos
viviendo en la calle a la intemperie a
merced de los fenómenos naturales como
hace cientos de miles de años
estaban sentados en un par de sillas
desvencijadas
tenían enfrente una caja de cartón
grande dada vuelta que hacía las veces
de mesa
mientras muchas otras cajas de cartón
apiladas a ambos costados de marcaban de
alguna manera su espacio semi privado en
la vía pública
estaba cenando juntos
y mientras comían miraban un celular
eran jóvenes sin techo pero con conexión
al entorno digital
esta escena sintetiza uno de los
hallazgos importantes de nuestras
investigaciones
y que la pertenece a un grupo etario la
edad suele ser más importante a la hora
de entender y explicar cómo habitamos el
entorno digital
que el género o incluso el nivel
socioeconómico
y esto de alguna manera marca el pasaje
del siglo 20 al 21
ahora
que esto pase en un país donde 3 de cada
10 personas viven debajo de la línea de
pobreza es un fenómeno sociológico
notable
el paso del tiempo es algo que nunca se
detiene todos los días de envejecemos lo
que en un momento fue novedoso va a
dejar de serlo y el recambio
generacional es inexorable
entonces si el paso del tiempo si la
edad es lo que organiza como habitamos
el entorno digital
eso significa que vivimos en una
sociedad en movimiento donde el cambio
es tal vez la única constante
y esto nos genera certidumbre a veces
nos preocupa otras incluso nos da
ansiedad
cómo va a ser el futuro
porque si yo estoy acostumbrado a algo
esto posiblemente vaya a cambiar
y es por esto que al menos en parte yo
creo que muchas veces se habla del
entorno digital evocando escenarios
apocalípticos
como por ejemplo la tormenta de noticias
falsas que va a destruir el edificio la
democracia
pero una sociedad en movimiento
es una sociedad en la cual es también
más posible vivir cambios
transformaciones sociales que antes eran
mucho menos probables
poses que fueron históricamente
marginadas y que tampoco tuvieron lugar
en los medios tradicionales tan
recientemente no sólo logrado hacerse
oír sino también dar impulso a
importantes reformas colectivas
hace tres años un tuit de un puntapié
inicial al movimiento ni una menos
desde aquel entonces las activistas se
han apropiado del entorno digital pero
organizarse visibilizar sus reclamos y
empoderar importantes sectores de la
ciudadanía
no es por las redes que este movimiento
social existe ni obviamente existe solo
en las redes
pero sin el entorno digital sería mucho
más difícil imaginar su existencia y su
fuerza
esto no significa que las noticias
falsas no se visualicen en las redes si
muchas veces se viraliza
pero significa que estas tendencias
negativas existen junto con las
posibilidades de reforma social que
vemos en casos tan esperanzadores como
ni una menos
y es en la lucha entre estas tendencias
negativas y positivas que se juega gran
parte del futuro del entorno digital y
tal vez de la sociedad en su conjunto
hoy leemos en los libros de historia
cómo fue el surgimiento de la
civilización urbana y su evolución a lo
largo de los siglos
y muchas veces a raíz de esas lecturas
nos preguntamos qué hubiera pasado con
nuestra sociedad si las ciudades se
hubieran diseñado y construido de
maneras distintas
pero nosotros somos los pioneros del
entorno digital
son nuestros descendientes quienes van a
leer en libros aún a ser escritos como
fueron estos años claves en la formación
del entorno digital
y muy posiblemente se hagan preguntas
bastante similares a las que nosotros
nos hacemos cuando leemos la historia de
las ciudades
que les gustaría que sus nietas sus
bisnietos sus tataranietas leyeran
acerca de los inicios del entorno
digital
y que el lugar quisieran tener ustedes
como sujetos y protagonistas no sólo
como espectadores en escribir esta
historia del futuro
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]